- Everybody
overthinks everything.
Everybody ponders everything.
Like the best strategy
is to fuckin' do. Enough.
Like everybody fuckin' debating.
Cynicism, "Oh Gary
I don't have 18 hours
"of sleep I should
sleep seven hours a day."
Good fuck face then
fuckin' execute in 17 hours.
("Unstoppable" by This Is Wolff)
("Faith" by T-Shawn)
- Sittin' back
here with Zach Nadler.
Show Zach!
You guys haven't seen
that beautiful face before
but Zach is at CAA
and books all my speaking.
We built a great relationship,
sorry Peter Jacobs
but Zach is my guy.
And is Peter your boss?
- [Zach] Yeah.
- Yeah fuck you Peter
Jacobs Zack is my guy.
Anyway here at
kind of more of an economic,
political kind
of big hedge fund,
big money Wall Street
but macro economic
like big wigs like
fancy people like Biden
and you know so
pretty interesting.
I feel like everybody
who knows who I am,
which is probably
three to 11% of the people
in the building
right now know that
this is gonna be an
interesting moment coming up
because maybe
you can here actually
let me be quite for
a second you can hear
the tone and the energy.
So no that's super unfair.
Obviously people
have their own styles
of communication
and their own skill sets
and but I'm gonna bring
a totally different energy
and then a bunch of networking,
a bunch of internal meetings.
Had a couple of
internal meetings this morning.
Just with AJ
about Vayner Sports,
spoke to a person that
runs our Chase business.
Big strat macro opportunities
there I'm excited about.
And then a red eye to
Canada, going to Montreal.
A couple hours of sleep, work
out, go to the conference,
couple meetings, and
then home late tomorrow.
It's been a long week.
A lot of I didn't
realize when we were talking
about nine, 10
flights I didn't realize
we had so many
connecting flights.
We took four flights yesterday.
Kansas city to Detroit,
Detroit to Ohio,
Ohio to Dallas, Dallas to Vegas.
The people must
have really understood
what was
happening in this device
and on the
platforms that represent
over 50% of the time of
Americans on this device,
they would take
this far more seriously.
If they actually
understood how much Facebook
targeted ads leads to
elections more so than a tweet.
If they understood
that right now there's a
$5 billion market
for Instagram influencers
where pretty
people or influencers take
a picture of a product
and sell them at a scale.
If they understood
that what's happened over
the last hundred
days with retail
is not really a
preview it's the complete
beginning of the
end of anybody who
has infrastructure
at retail with
the overhead of
leases of brick and mortar
because we're just hitting
the crescendo, my friends.
The level of
destruction that is coming
is extraordinary
and in the short term
and I really just
genuinely don't know
what most of you
do here for a living,
but in the short
term I promise you
the incumbents that don't,
the level of
Walmart and Target being
out of business in
my head is extreme.
The level of the
biggest fashion brands
in the world being out
of business is extreme.
You know, when I think
about how vulnerable
the Nikes and the
Under Armours are because
of cool kids on Instagram
it sounds subtle and funny
but everything that
fucks you in the end
sounds funny and
subtle in the beginning.
You know you have seen
the long term legacy CEO
that said screw you
Wall Street for the short term.
I'm gonna win in the
end for legacy 'cause
I've made enough money and
you've seen what that means.
When you understand
when they look the part
of Bezos and they
look the part of Zuckerberg
and they are the layer on
top of the internet itself
for communication
and consumption
you need to understand how
extreme that actually plays out.
So please stop
thinking that this is
your 16 year old
teenage girls behavior.
This is actually
your behavior you
just haven't deployed it
into your business life yet
'cause it's not in your short
term financial interest.
Thank you.
(audience applause)
("Faith" by T-Shawn)
- [Woman] And I'm
working on my money,
and I'm always wondering,
like, what social media,
like, how do you choose
what social media--
- Facebook would
convert for you guys so much.
- [Woman] What do you say
to say what you want,
because the
different social medias
are for different purposes.
- 100%.
I think you're
always reverse engineering
the psychology of
the end user, right?
What I love
about Facebook, though,
is they're sitting on
such ungodly amounts of data.
So, the fact that I can go,
so, knowing a lot
about online learning,
the fact that you can go after
28 to 41 year old
female single moms.
- [Rebecca] Right.
I know, well--
- It's just so crazy.
- [Rebecca] I know, I know.
- And what's happening is that
Google's intent
marketing product,
which was so
amazing in the early 2000's,
has gotten so overpriced,
super competitive.
But Rebecca,
everybody here in line
is vulnerable at the
variable of the creative.
- [Rebecca] I know.
- If you don't actually
get them to give a shit
when you got in front
of them, it doesn't work.
But on the flip side,
if you get it right,
Facebook's the only
place where we can have
"Just Do It," or
"Where's the Beef?"
or MasterCard Priceless,
and you can do it
for a 1/100th of a price.
- [Man] I'm a
business professor.
Where do you see this
going in higher education?
- I think it's disruptive.
- Right.
- I think universities
trade on brand,
and they're
starting to dilute it with
their online courses,
and what do they call these?
These "merks," or what's the
term for eight-week courses
that kids are now
running around and saying that
they went to
Harvard and Stanford.
I don't think
Harvard and Stanford,
and these
organizations understand that
the only thing they
actually have is brand.
And that you, actually, as the
professor, has the leverage.
And in a 20-30 year macro,
I think it's going to
be enormously destructive.
- [Man] Right, wow. Interesting.
Look forward to
reading your book.
- I mean, you still, you
basically got a situation
where the far majority of
people go after it because,
because of what their parents
think, or what they think.
- [Man] Yeah.
- And as that continues
to dilute, it gets very--
I mean, it's fascinating
to me the emails I get from
15, 16 year-old straight "A,"
hardcore private school kids.
- [Man] Mhmmm.
- The cracks are
in the foundation.
Now, macroeconomic meltdown,
not as easy to
be an entrepreneur.
But the problem is
what emerges from that,
I actually think is
more cost effective.
It's just going to
be very interesting.
- [Man] Yeah, I think so.
- There's a lot
coming, a lot coming.
- [Man] Pleasure, right.
- Stay well.
- Jack Riley,
very nice to meet you, Gary.
- A real pleasure, Jack.
- I worked briefly in
New York for Adam Roth.
- No kidding.
- [Jack] Very briefly.
- On POP, or--
- [Jack] Yeah.
- Very cool, man.
- [Jack] In 2011, in
their tiny little office.
- I'm going to Ghana
next week, two weeks.
Very cool, man.
- [Jack] Yeah, and that's
initially where I heard of you.
Do you know Eddie...
- Rizzo?
- [Jack] Eddie Rizzo, yeah.
- Yeah, he just moved to L.A.,
he's been with us for
five years, best dude.
Awesome, man, real
pleasure, take care.
- It was nice to
meet you, take care.
- Alright,
21 year-old Rick, Sally.
Here's the motivation,
it's real simple.
There's only two core
things you need to be doing.
You need to be pulling
from opposite directions.
You need to be patient
as fuck, I mean patient.
You need to realize
at 33, you're still a kid.
And number two, you need
to be doing a ton of shit,
moving really fast,
trying different things,
and figuring out
what you're about, period.
Two very opposite contradictions
that will pretty much
create the biggest upside
in the framework of life.
- Awesome, man, thank you.
- Real pleasure.
Take care of yourself.
("Jazzy" by Emapea)
I'm about to do
this interview with Yahoo,
and you're happy
because there's good light.
- [Man 2] Yeah, (laughs)
and you killed the talk.
- Thank you.
- [Man 2] Well done.
- Yeah, it was a good one.
- Could we lose this
mic for the interview?
- [DRock] Um.
- Can we be on
separate frequencies?
- It's fine that
you're...it's just a look thing.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- It's just appearances.
- I like the double mic.
- [DRock] Can we
hide it in your shirt?
- [Interviewer] Double mic-ing?
- [DRock]
Can we hide it like,
(microphone
rubbing against shirt)
would that be okay?
- Yeah, that would be better.
That's better,
thank you, appreciate it.
- Gary, thanks for joining us.
- Thanks for having me.
- Okay, you were just in
there giving your talk--
- Yes.
- to a crowd of
hedge fund managers.
You were sharing your story.
You're an immigrant to the U.S.
- I am.
- So, what do you
think the status is
of the American dream today?
- Oh, I think it's
massively alive and well.
You know, I think,
as a matter of fact,
I think the internet,
being at scale today,
has compounded the opportunity.
When I see a lot of
people who feel like,
the political
climate, for example,
is suppressing a
female or a minority,
I always try to
remind them, like,
"Look, this is
the best time ever.
The internet doesn't care
what you look like," right?
You can go direct to
consumer with your offering.
Nobody needs to be in your way,
and so I would argue that
this is the greatest time.
So much so, that as
an early-stage investor,
I've actually
stopped investing 'cause
everybody now is a founder
and a startup entrepreneur,
and the supply and
demand of actual good operators
has scared me so much.
And it's a little
bit of a guess game,
and I don't know
who's a real entrepreneur
and who's a fake one.
But I would tell you that it
is extremely alive and well.
- Do you think there's a
lot of noise on social media
in terms of politics,
and how do you navigate that?
I can't, I open up my Facebook,
it's just politics
from both sides.
- I have good news.
There's noise on
politics on television, too.
When something like the
political climate goes extreme,
it encompasses our environment.
I think that
socials are very easy.
You can absolutely
curate smaller lists.
On Twitter, you can
create a "non-political" list,
follow people.
I'm not doing a lot on politics.
There's a lot of comedians
who are doing politics.
Jimmy Fallon's not doing pol--
So, the reality is
that, you have so much control
of your media
consumption in a environment.
The problem is 94% of people
are playing in that sector,
and if that's not what you want,
then that's hard to navigate
to create your perfect lists.
- Gary Vaynerchuk
of VaynerMedia,
thanks for coming by.
- Thanks for having me.
- [Woman 2] What
is your morning routine?
- My morning
routine is just like,
bathroom,
shower, brush my teeth.
I grab my phone right away,
make sure there's no emergency.
My biggest fear is
something's going on in London
that I need to
address as soon as I wake up,
or something
happened with a client
that I'm not in control of.
So, first it's intense.
It's like, make
sure everything's okay.
Then, I kind of catch up on
my inbox and my social media.
So, within the first 30 minutes,
it's pretty
intense of collecting data.
Then I work out,
and then I go to my
first breakfast meeting,
either at eight o'clock or
nine o'clock in the morning.
Self-awareness,
empathy, those are chemicals.
You may not be gifted with that,
but the reason I talk so much
about hustle and hard work
is for everybody here, it is
fundamentally controllable.
It's just controllable.
It doesn't come
natural to everybody,
but working out
didn't come natural to me.
I was 38 years
old when I finally
got my shit
together a little bit
and started getting into shape.
That's how
I think about work ethic.
Maybe you grew up in a family
where nobody worked that hard.
You never saw it.
You're 37, but
you can change that,
and I will
always push hard work.
("Jazzy" by Emapea)
I feel like
I'm about to gamble.
- [Zach] You a gambler?
- [Gary] I can be.
(laughing)
I can be sold on it.
Actually I have a funny feeling
on number five please.
- [Man 3] Straight up?
- [Gary] Straight up.
- [Man 3] Speed racer fan?
- [Gary] No, is he number five?
It's really crazy,
I was five when I decided
what my favorite number was.
That's how it happened.
- I watched Speed
Racer when I was a kid
and now I'm like number five
is my favorite
number ever since.
- [Gary] Well Jarrod, I hope
there's a prayer here.
Nope. Not AJ.
Don't be 28
that would bother me.
(laughing)
Good.
The only two numbers
I play are five and 28.
Thank you brother!
That would have bothered me.
- [Zach] AJ.
- [Gary] AJ's
birthday is January 28th.
I'm my best when I'm combative.
- [Zach] Yes.
- [Gary] When I know
I'm walking into
I would be such a great
quarterback on the road.
(laughing)
There's a different
thing that happens to me.
When I get into that.
- [Zach] 'Cause it's easy to
feel relaxed when you know
people are eating it up.
- You know why?
I'm addicted to adversity.
It's why I love the process.
It's why I love the
chip on my shoulder.
It's why I'm winning.
Everybody wants it good.
Everybody's a
fucking peace time general.
Everybody just wants to kind
of do it and have it awesome.
I want it to be shit!
I love adversity!
I like people booing.
I like being a Jets fan.
- Zach Bryce I just
wanted to track you down.
Loved the talk.
First of all, my friend
and my buddy from college,
Mike Vacanti.
- Yes.
- Trained you.
- I am very aware.
- He's the best.
- Phenomenal guy.
- Is that your buddy?
- That's my buddy.
- That's amazing.
Mike is like family
to me at this point.
- I saw him, so we
both went to Wisconsin
and we actually
were watching the
Wisconsin basketball games,
so we were just hanging out.
He's such a great guy.
- I love it.
Thanks for saying hello,
I'm getting on the phone.
- No you go ahead,
do what you gotta do.
- Take care.
- Love your talk.
- Thank you brother.
("Jazzy" by Emapea)
- Is that right?
- Great dude and obviously he
talked about his experience
with you and I was like
that's freaking awesome man.
- That's awesome man.
- Inspiration and perspective
are two really
big things for me.
- I'm glad you said perspective.
I think inspiration
I hear everyday
perspective I've
rarely heard anybody say.
Appreciate that 'cause honestly,
I think I'm doing a lot
more perspective hacking
than I'm doing
inspirational hacking.
- How one views the world--
- Is the binary way of
how it's gonna play out.
- Absolutely right.
And how you view
every single situation,
how you react to it
- It's everything.
- It's unbelievable.
- Yeah.
- It's a black and white switch.
- Yeah, it really is.
- Cool man.
Real pleasure man.
- Nice to meet you sir.
- Thanks for saying hello.
Wish you well.
- What is it?
What does that mean?
Help me.
I'm being serious.
I'm in it now.
I'm fuckin' in it!
All four of you stop
doing what you're doing.
I want all four of
you capable of doing it
by middle of next week.
I don't give a
shit what you guys do.
You're big
fucking boys and girls.
I want all four of
you to be able to do it.
I want it done ASAP.
Wednesday of next
week, the four of you
and if you tell me 98 other
people can do it, Mazel Tov,
I want it fuckin' done.
I want it done right now.
("Chirp" by T-Shawn)
Good to see you.
Niko good to see you.
Hello King Nidas.
Good to see you Exotic.
Good to see you, Raj.
Hello, hello, hello.
Good to see everybody.
Just got off a really
interesting conversation
with some core people at Vayner.
Fired up!
Speed.
Process cripples people.
We put process and subjective
creative on a pedestal.
Following rules.
It just fuckin' sucks.
It doesn't allow you to
build trillion dollar things.
And I think it's a huge mistake.
I think it's a
huge, huge mistake
and I'm not a fan.
Anyway, what else going on?
Good to see you Khalid.
Andrea, great to see you.
Any advice when you
want to change careers?
Change 'em.
That's my fuckin' advice.
It's perfect timing.
Everybody overthinks everything.
Everybody ponders everything.
The best
strategy is to fuckin' do.
Enough.
Everybody fuckin' debating.
Cynicism,
"Oh Gary, I don't
have 18 hours of sleep,
"I should sleep 7 hours a day".
Good fuck face,
then fuckin'
execute on 17 hours.
Everybody cares
about all the details
and all these fuckin' shit
that doesn't fuckin' matter.
Think about
fuckin' changing careers.
Change careers!
Who gives a fuck?
That's it!
You don't need me on
fuckin' Instagram Live
telling you to do it.
You don't need
your mom to do it.
You know, just fuckin' do it!
If you can afford it, do it!
And if you can't afford it,
fuckin' sell your house
and fuckin' rent an apartment.
If you're so fuckin' miserable
you want to change careers,
change careers!
Fuck.
Fuckin' everybody
just thinking about
just fuckin' do shit!
If I fuckin' thought through
everything I've done in my life
I wouldn't have done anything.
None of it made sense.
Hey let's document everything
and then create micro content.
Let's fuckin' invest
in these fuckin' companies
that nobody's
ever fuckin' heard of.
Let's fuckin' sell
wine on the internet.
Fuckin' do shit!
Fuck!
Everybody fuckin'...
Like, really?
It's gonna be a fuckin'
motivational post on my
Instagram page or fuckin'
lifestyle self improvement this
or fuckin' Oprah.
God.
Fuckin' do!
Shit!
I have no idea how to measure
EQ, it's just people skills,
if somebody's
got it, they have it.
I'm fired up to
double a farm from Brooklyn.
Form, whatever!
Maddie you're a fuckin' clown!
Fuck you!
You know.
Little bitch, come see me.
Fuckin' Maddie Yankee.
Come see me,
little fuckin' bitch!
(laughing)
- I'm kidding, Maddy.
I hope you win.
I'm sorry that
you think I'm a clown
but I hope you win.
I'm just fired up today.
Like I just want people to win.
I just want you
guys to do stuff.
I miss you, too, Tyler Babin.
(DRock laughs)
I really hope you guys are well.
I just want good for everybody.
By the way I do have
something I wanna talk about.
Which is, on the flip side,
I feel like too many people
that are building audiences
or have created
some level of success,
you gotta verified account,
you're an amazing founder,
like Morrin.
Jim Quick, me, like
I think way too many people
are dismissing people that
disagree with them
as haters.
Or trolls and I hate that.
I think it's massively
important to be empathetic.
I think empathy is
an enormous strength
in today's
environment where everybody
has things to say and
things that their two cents.
I would really,
really, really implore
the 4,000 plus of
you that are watching
right now to not dismiss people
that leave negative comments.
Obviously people are like
you're you know derogatory
terms or sexist terms or just
really dirty gnarly stuff,
of course of course
that's not acceptable
but people that are
pushing back and some of
you have seen some of
the interactions I've had
with people in
the street that kid
in London or other places.
I think it's imperative
to understand criticism
but it's also important
for you to stay your course.
Like I hear criticism
all the time which I think
is actually right if you
take a Snapchat of today.
The problem is I'm
not playing for today.
My life is not
predicated on today.
And so I'm just I'm really...
Really looking for people
to factor in people's feedback
and not be as
dismissive and realize
how powerful empathy is.
How much it's a
foundation of success.
See ya!
That was a good one.
- [Gary on Phone] My one
reservation with this video
is that it's gonna turn a
lot of you into spam bots.
- That's interesting.
- [Gary on Phone] That
you're just gonna control copy,
go into DM and start
pasting and getting banned
or paused by Instagram.
The 48,000 followers
to see what they post.
I want you to click
the URL that is linked
to that person's account
and look at their website.
If they have...
- This is awesome!
- [DRock] I have a question.
- Go ahead.
- [DRock] Isn't
documenting like journaling.
- Yeah I think
documenting is like journaling.
I think obviously yeah
sure I mean absolutely.
- [DRock] You know
like back in the day
people just literally
journalled their lives.
- Yeah I mean I just think
you have to put out content.
Speed and volume.
Facebook, speed and volume.
That is huge.
You have to have speed
and you have to have volume,
and the problem is
most people struggle
with both and that's why most
people aren't successful.
I mean like the
reason you're not breaking out
is two of the
pillars besides quality
are speed and volume.
And the third one's quality.
Like that's the formula.
The formula is speed, quantity,
quantity, and quality.
That's it.
And the third one
you can't control.
Like not everybody's
gonna be charismatic,
not everybody's gonna be funny,
not everybody's
gonna be attractive.
But the other two
you can if you break it.
And I'm struggling with, so
many people are struggling
with putting out
compelling content,
they are half-assing it,
because they're overthinking
their content, and then
that means they are slow.
When you overthink,
you slow down.
When you're slow,
somebody passes you.
I mean, I don't fucking,
fucking just turn on this
Facebook Live right now, and
I'm like, what, here we go.
I don't know, what do you think?
Right, Jason Nash?
Like, I don't know what
I'm gonna talk about here.
I'm just gonna talk about what
I'm living, what I'm feeling.
What I'm doing, how I'm
going, what I'm thinking.
Where I'm going, how I'm doing.
I want you to go
fucking listen to me and work
and figure yourself out
and get rid of poison people
in your life, and put in
work, and leave your fucking
excuses at the door
of poverty, or
broken homes, or heritage,
or immigrant status,
or skin color or gender.
I just want you to
leave them all at the door,
complete mindset.
They're true.
I'm not dismissing them.
They're true, I just want you
to think they're fucking fake
so you can fucking go.
- [DRock] They're downstairs,
ready for you.
- They're ready for us?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- All right. I gotta go,
I was in the middle.
You fucked up, DRock.
I could have been three minutes
late for that horseshit.
I was in the middle.
you even know it.
I can see your face, you know!
Guys, it's DRock.
Guys, no, listen!
You guys admit it,
admit it, admit that DRock
just, DRock, admit to
everybody that I was in it,
that I was rolling, the good
shit was about to come out.
- [DRock] Yeah, I hate myself.
- You're upset, right?
- [DRock] I do.
- Because you took
something that was a commodity,
which is like, let's
just be on time to something
that means nothing,
for three minutes.
Guys, I'm really sorry.
- [DRock] I haven't been
yelled at for not making
sure you're not on time.
- I'm really sorry guys.
I'm sorry, I gotta go now.
That's it. I lost it,
I lost my mojo.
If you're mad at
DRock like I am,
let's do this.
DRock, we're gonna
do a DRock contest.
Here we go.
DRock, what the fuck?
#DRockwhatthefuck?
DRock, we're going to
turn this into a positive.
You are a negative, I'm
gonna turn it into a positive
right now, DRock.
There we go, guys.
It's right here, take
this screen shot right now.
I'm gonna give you a
couple seconds, get over here.
Good lighting, DRock.
You fucked up,
you ruined the day.
Alright, take a screen
shot right now, screen your,
screen it, screen it,
pan it from the side.
You know what to do.
We're gonna do a contest,
screen this, screen this.
I'm gonna give you a couple
more seconds before I set it up.
Screen this, screen
shoot this right now.
Post on your Instagram this
#DRockwhatthefuck?
I'm gonna give you one
full minute starting taking
screen shots.
Use this, DRockwhatthefuck
hashtag in your post,
and I'm gonna pick one
of you and I'm gonna fly you
to New York City and
you're going to shadow DRock
for the day, which means you're
shadowing me for the day.
Everybody screen shoot right
now, post this, post this.
Use the hashtag
DRockwhatthefuck.
So, you're not
coming to this, right?
("Faith" by T-Shawn)
- [DRock] (laughs) I want
to know what's going on here.
I'm gonna rotate that shot.
- [Woman 4] May I
have your attention please.
Paging Jason Scallana,
Jason Scallana.
Please dial zero,
Please dial zero from an
airport courtesy telephone
for the operator.
("Faith" by T-Shawn)